I don't know I would like to think that
you can keep making great work late in
your career you know there are all these
examples where you know mathematicians
did their most important work at 25 or
whatever and then they never did
anything significant after that I just
turned 59 I've been in games 23 years
you know Deus Ex did very well game of
the year dishonored won same thing this
dishonored twos got over a hundred best
sub Awards so far like we're very very
proud of and we're very lucky honestly
but like the question is like what
drives you and honestly there's this
sense of desperation like how many more
years in games do I have can I be
working on games at 60 or 65 that's
crazy but I'm just getting to this point
where I feel like I get it and I feel
like I can bring something more to the
player and make a better crafted
experience for the audience
[Music]
the story of Arkane studios is a
turbulent one the team began in France
with four people and limited funding its
first game was well received but its
complexity and niche appeal ensured that
it didn't sell incredibly well as the
years passed arcane worked on three
cancelled projects did supporting work
on three others and struggled to make a
name for itself as a top-tier developer
but under the guidance of raphaël
colantonio and Harvey Smith our Cannes
creative two-headed dog the studio
finally found its way
it released dishonored in 2012 a game
that hearkened back to the days when
Looking Glass Studios and origin systems
continually shaped the RPG genre back to
the days when people such as Warren
Spector and Richard Garriott passed down
lessons to those with similar passions
for complex games with fully realized
worlds dishonored became our Kane's
breakout hit cementing the team as a
renowned developer of sophisticated
games but then with newfound success and
increased pressure Arkane Studios was
forced to re-examine its identity as it
moved into the uncertain future a lot of
people have asked like how did that work
co-create of directing a game especially
given that Raph and I are both very
opinionated and have very strong
feelings about little things in a game
sometimes big strokes but sometimes like
little nitpicky details will just like
get really into you know at first before
we starting to work together I think we
both feared that it would be a little
difficult you know how do you have two
two chefs in the same kitchen it's hard
and it requires like at some point I
felt like we should actually take like
couples counseling or whatever because
during Dishonored one there would be
such intense arguments over things we
shared an office and so very often we'd
shut the door and we'd like have it out
before we talked to the team
tanka I think it worked out as a nice
back and forth styling and the game is a
is a mix of both our tastes and and you
know 80% of the time we were were saying
the same thing exactly the same thing
and then there's like 20% of the time we
disagree and most of the time would make
something better by disagreeing and it
was just an ongoing very intense
experience for three years I would say
it changed me as a person and not just
as a game developer and Raph would
probably say the same thing we both came
out of it better but we also both said
like holy cow that was like that was so
intense like what do you want to do in
the next project and I was like man I'm
so excited about the Sun or two whatever
it takes I want to work on the Sun or
two and then after that on when we're
ready we were in a position where we had
both neo and Austin
that both grew and so it was great time
to to you know take off with both
actually and do one game in each on each
side so that's when Harvey volunteered
to to go to France which was pretty big
deal and I moved moved there for a few
years and looking at the schedule the
production the project planning that
could be done better and quicker by the
team in lyon while the austin auth
office needed some staffing up and
needed more time to percolate on what
they wanted to work on and so the only
answer there was for me to move to lyon
to work with those guys very talented
french guys
so i packed up and moved to lyon for
four years to make this on or two
meanwhile that freed raff up to work on
prey as a company as our akane working
on two different game was most of all
because they are shipping with six
months difference it's it's a pretty big
endeavor it's been a big challenge and
thankfully i think both sides are
independent enough from each other that
there was no there was no true damage
done you know if we were close to each
other like a lot of companies have two
studios in the in the same floor or
something then usually that goes bad
because as soon as one start to be laid
they stop poaching people from the other
team etc with the distance that really
avoided this kind of thing so i think it
forced us into some sort of discipline
which actually paid off for us for the
first time since its inception Arkane
studios went to work on two simultaneous
projects in austin : Tonio led
development on prey and despite
comparisons to the 2006 game with the
same title our cannes version was
something wholly new a chance for the
studio to branch into new areas of
creative development meanwhile in france
smith directed work on Dishonored 2 and
as our cannes first sequel ever it
presented its own set of problems you
know Dishonored 2 is a sequel which is
an interesting thing right dishonored 1
was a new IP which is its own challenge
but sequel is equally hard if not harder
in ways with Dishonored one you're
trying to convey to everyone what is
this thing
what's different about it what is it
with the Sun or two you don't have that
challenge of getting it because a lot of
people were already excited about it you
have other challenges how much you
reinvent it because if it's too familiar
people are like ah feels like a 1.5 if
it's too different they're like wow you
deviated from the pattern that I love
and I can tell you from experience
that's a really tricky balance I worked
on Deus Ex 1 and 2 and C quilling our
game Deus Ex was really hard we were
very afraid of repeating ourselves you
know and and so we probably changed too
much went too far into the future and
you know in some ways disappointed fans
in the first game so yeah we did a lot
of things for dishonor too you know not
only did we double up the characters in
the cities but we really took all the
core systems the stealth and the combat
and we were a little nervous about this
but the game design team felt very
strongly about deepening all of that and
so you know you have things like slight
assassinations slide knock down window
assassination where you eat you know you
might not even know these things
it sounds like developers speak but like
as a player you feel it
some guy the target walks by and you're
on the other side of a glass window and
you can grab them through the glass and
you yank him through the glass and
killing just pay the fine and be done
with it so there are lots of little
tweaks like that that we made to the
core systems the core combat the core
stealth that make it feel like a much
deeper game it's hard for people to see
when they approach a sequel but what you
really have to do is kind of fire up the
first game play for an hour to then fire
up the second game play for an hour -
and then you notice all these things
that if we're doing our job right you
don't actually notice them when you're
playing they just enhance the experience
for Dishonored one I felt like a
structure where the missions were
discrete you wake up in the morning you
get the briefing and go on the mission
at the end of the mission you come back
and it fades to black when the next
mission picks up it could have been two
days it could have been a week you don't
know you have a vague sense of time that
makes it plausible right like oh I just
killed eight of the most important
people in the country and the whole
government's falling because of my
actions how long did that take you know
like if you do a timeline of Star Wars
like
goes from like farm boy to master Jedi
and like I don't know what it is at 12
days or 21 days or something like that
it's like wow that's an accelerated
program and so the discreet missions
makes it feel a little more murky in
that sense like you can imagine whatever
time makes sense to you and I think
sometimes that's the right call for
games like this where the story is
playing out across an arc or whatever
but we rappin are both very drawn to
this idea of a contiguous space where
real time passes and the first minute of
the game is the first minute of the game
and the 30th hour of the game is the
30th hour of the game and it's plausible
that everything that happens happens in
one stretch of time and further the
space itself can be traversed back and
forth in prey you can leave an airlock
spend your time space walk and go around
the station and go in another airlock in
another spot and approach one of the
levels that you that are intended for
later from the opposite direction
it's very much a simulated contiguous
environmental space and so toward the
end of Dishonored one RAF was already
saying like my next game is going to be
that kind of contiguous space game and I
was like that's exciting you know I love
those games too and so prey is very much
that kind of game
[Music]
tre is more focused on survival you are
trapped on board of a Space Station
where there are hostile aliens and
really you don't have much with you on
your own and you need to escape and so
that's the main difference in terms of
drive and power fantasy and also the
structure unlike dishonored which is
mission based this one is more like one
big contiguous space so it's kind of
like it's a persistent open world in a
way on board of a Space Station which
you can explore in and out you can also
fly around in Serie G we did not
necessarily go as weird I don't afraid
is the word but as exotic as as
dishonored simply because I think our
focus was somewhere else we wanted to go
exotic on the aliens but we did
transgress the worlds to some degree in
prey because we actually rewrote part of
the history of the real world in our
world we came back to the 60s and
decided that somehow Kennedy had
survived its assassination and then
that's a what-if moment where a lot of
things have changed from there not
enough that you feel like this is kind
of a weird world I don't understand
where I am but enough that it's it is a
little off and therefore calls for your
curiosity I think and that's that's what
we wanted so when you explore the world
of prey it does feel familiar but it
also feels different and you want to
know why all these things are a little
different and you start to get used to
this new world and you
ality I think there's no no such thing
as reales emits more cohesiveness or
something once you make a world and you
announce the rules in the codes to the
player in your world maybe there's no
doors or maybe you know every object is
read whatever are the rules as long as
they are consistent and all along your
experience you can rely on those rules
to always work together then that's when
the players can actually make their own
strategies and come up with with some
expectations that actually work and
everything that happens is actually
logical it kind of triggers this this
feeling of I'm there I'm immersed in
this thing and everything is actually
responding to what I want which is not
necessarily realistic
but it's it's cohesive consistent I
think there's no stronger than
narratives than the one that are somehow
generated by the player and their
actions
Dishonored 2 release in October of 2016
garnering numerous accolades in game of
the Year awards for Smith's team in
France prey on the other hand released
only weeks ago and although its
reception was more divisive than
dishonored twos it was praised for
similar reasons player empowerment
emergent systems and a cohesive fully
realized world both prey and dishonour
to follow the same tenets of our Kane's
earlier games and the games of Looking
Glass Studios and origin systems these
companies whose creative direction
influenced generations of developers
making games today
but despite talks about level design
mission structure and narrative
direction something else emerged in our
talks with our Cannes creative leaders
something deeper something that drives
them on an emotional level yeah I think
across all media there are works that
are directly autobiographical and then
there are works that are like very
indirectly autobiographical and when
you're talking about games like this
sometimes you're talking about a hundred
people working on a game so it feels
like oh wow how could it possibly have
any authorial Drive but like in terms of
driving the emotional piece and the like
themes behind a literary sense behind
the work that's a small handful of
people and they're all bringing their
own their own thing for both me and
Raphael like both of us lost our moms
really early and both of us like grew up
in environments that were not entirely
safe you know like I've talked at length
about my mom died she od'd when I was
having lunch with her when I was six my
dad was physically abusive he eventually
killed himself you know not to go into
dark territory because that was a long
time ago and I live a very privileged
life now you know I've had a great time
in the industry but like that shapes you
in a way that you never recover from in
some ways as much as you work on it and
so like there's a lot of mother trauma
and family dynamics in the games I've
worked on the Deus Ex and dishonored
series for sure because those things are
things that resonate for me
they still like elicit some kind of like
thing I'm grappling with you know they
elicit some feeling but then on top of
that like for both me and Raph like
being vulnerable and being dropped into
like a malevolent dark dirty place where
you not only have to serve
five you have to master the environment
and come out on top and master the thing
that you were afraid of that is a very
powerful experience for a lot of people
not just us but a lot of kids out there
a lot of players out there and so say
what you will about those types of games
that's I think why we make stealth games
I think that's I'm not strong enough to
defeat everybody in the world but I may
be clever enough and quick enough to
flee at the right moment or to get
behind the enemy or to get above them
you know it's a I think at an abstract
level that's really what's going on in
those games and then that felt like you
were actually in a true world that would
transport you and where everything you
do is actually see what you participate
to this world that already exists on its
own but you're in there to hopefully
influence it and I think and that then
leads to all those choices and all the
things that we always like in our games
and the ambiguity of characters like
it's not like they're either a friend or
foe all of them have an inventory they
have a little schedule they do their own
thing and then it might attack you might
not their interaction with you is
actually based on what you do ring I
want to do more of that and I want to
use this time when I finally feel like I
figured a lot of things out finally
figured out X Y & Z about games and what
how to get what I want into the game and
it's taken a long time I guess that's
ongoing it's not a binary thing but it's
but it's ongoing but it would have
reached some point and now how many more
years do I have to apply that like
honestly is it ten is five like I don't
know and so there's really a sense of
desperation we're like it must be like a
hate to use a sports metaphor at 18
sports minute but you know they say this
thing about quarterbacks where they have
a peak level of athleticism at what 25
or something but they don't know the
game intuitively yet and then they hit
this point later like when they're 30 or
something where they have a sense they
read the field they know when they're
going to get hit even though they don't
see the guy because like oh my god he's
not over here I bet Oh yet there he is
you know and there's this sweet spot
where their physicality and their
like field experience are at this
perfect point but then they pass that
their physicality starts fall they've
had one too many concussions or they
ripped up a knee or whatever but their
sense of the game and their their
ability to motivate the team and to call
the right play and to drop that play and
improvise goes up at the end it must be
very frustrating to like to realize that
like if I just had my body from ten
years ago I would be a master at this
game now and I think maybe game
developers feel some of that same thing
like the clock is running out but I
finally get it you know as long as
you're learning and as long as rounded
by smart people that challenge you which
is definitely the case that art gained I
think you can still I think you can
still learn and great teams are very
often made of a handful of very smart
green people that you've pulled in from
a diverse crowd of people that are just
getting their start a but rest' by
veterans that have gone through this
over and over and they know why that
thing won't work or why maybe you need
to tweak it a little bit and that
combination of youthful energy and
experience is very powerful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]